hi everybody hi thanks for coming
there's so many awesome talks going on
thanks for your interest I'm assuming
you're here because you like c'mere
interested in math education or at the
least how could you write an algorithm
that teaches people math and like a
human-like way which is what we'll be
talking about today but all right
I must click the button so before we
dive in I want to just like take a step
back and talk for a minute about how do
humans think about math because to write
an algorithm that solves math like a
human would we first have to figure out
how a human would think about math and
so here's some math I don't know about
you but when I look at this I don't just
see a bunch of characters it's not just
like a 2 and then a 0 and then a plus
sign and when you read a book you're
also not looking at like individual
letters you group them together into
words and the words become like
sentences and you breed them with some
kind of tone and so that's because
you've learned rules about how the
English language work or other languages
and so you also have rules in your mind
for how math works and so I know that
division happens before addition and I
group that together in my mind and I
know that that happens first and 8
divided by 4 is 2 and then I can add
that to 20 and get 22 and I kind of all
do that without like thinking at all I
just know that it's 22 because my mind
has learned all these rules and it can
apply them really quickly here's some
more math I'm just sort of curious I
think that your mind applies more
meaning to this than there isn't just
the characters too like do you see the
2x as a unit like do you see it as 2x
over 3 there's no like parentheses
around the 2x but you're probably still
seeing it as a unit as 2x or maybe you
see it as 2x over 3 so like who sees it
as the one on the left
awesome I'm on the right cool so we do
person s on the left so that's good
because that means that's more likely to
be how you're thinking about it or maybe
you see it as like 2/3 X and you might
be wondering nice anyone that like
wasn't either of anything that I showed
cool and you might be wondering like
what why isn't matter these are all
mathematically equivalent but I think
that when you show a step by step
solution being able to even just like
print it on the screen and the right way
that they're thinking about it is
important but also being able to like
the step by step solution might be
different like the one on the left
that's one fraction the one on the right
that's like a number times a fraction so
what you might do to show the step by
step solution might be different I think
that if there was a space here it might
change the way you purse it like this
this change anyone's answer maybe yeah
so like I think that one would be the
one on the right but then they like get
weird questions like what if it's 2 plus
X thirds a mixed fraction or something
and now it's this is a different math
thing and anyway the point is a string
of math which is the input to this
algorithm we're going to be talking
about can be interpreted by our minds in
lots of different ways and thinking
about how humans think about math it's
kind of what we're going to be getting
into you so thinking about how do humans
think about and solve math how could an
algorithm solve math and can algorithms
follow the same logic that a human would
what we'll be talking about all great
questions so today we're going to be
talking about I'll start by introducing
myself we'll talk about why math steps
which is this algorithm why it was built
and how it was built and not just how it
produces some step-by-step solution but
a step-by-step solution that can provide
a good learning experience we'll talk
about some of the limitations of math
steps because all technology has its
flaws and its limitations and we'll also
talk about the future of my steps and
like things that could be done with tech
to do stuff for a math education so
let's get into it
my name is Evie hello I am a computer
science student at the University of
Waterloo
and I'm really interested in education
I'm currently interning at asana on
their infrastructure team but being a
Waterloo student I've done like a whole
bunch of internships more than on this
slide and in general I'm like really
interested in working on technology
related to how people think about things
and I like working on technology that
does social good and that's sort of why
I started working on this at one of my
internships at a company called Socratic
Socratic is an app I worked there
a year ago and they make an app or you
take a picture of your homework it scans
it it figures out what you're asking
what subject it is and then it provides
you a bunch of like teaching resources
to learn more about that topic and help
you solve your homework and when I got
there they were like just thinking about
doing math stuff so they were like oh it
turns out like half of our queries are
math because everyone takes math
everyone takes it like every year school
and once you like get one part that's
kind of challenging you're like scarred
for the rest of your like educational
career because everything we build on
each other and a lot of people just end
up like having a lot of trouble with
math it was something that I really
enjoyed like I was able to have like
really good teachers and resources and I
really enjoy like showing my work and
doing math but a lot of people don't and
they come to the app to mouth questions
and so we wanted to provide a
step-by-step solution a good
step-by-step solution and how do we
define good it should be detailed which
means not just here's the answer but
like some steps along the way of how
that happened it should have good
explanations
so like why that's thing that step
happened and it should be intuitive
because there's lots of ways to get to
the answer but some of them a human will
be like well why did you like that makes
no sense and some of them will be
intuitive to them based off of how they
learn to do in school and stuff and it
should pretty much be like a human tutor
but like not human and this is what it
looked like in the socratic app when I
finished my internship it scans like a
picture of math which is not
my steps at all but it's just really
cool so I want to show you this math OCR
um then takes that and then it has this
like step by step solution that you can
look through I wanted to mention that
math steps only does algebra right now
so it's like simplifying expressions
solving equations the Socratic app has a
private fork of the code and they added
some calculus support but that's kind of
the extent the the scope of what we'll
be talking about today so you might be
wondering there's already like step by
step math solvers out there why build a
new one and the main answer is we wanted
something that we could use and hello
the existing ones are close source so we
built our own and then we made it open
source so that other people can also
work on it and make it good and stuff
like that it's also worth noting that
like even some of the existing math
solvers out there like Wolfram Alpha not
free anymore it was free when I was
doing integrals but now if you want an
integral step-by-step solution you have
to pay like two bucks a month for it or
something so and we wanted to make sure
that we were focused on teaching so
there's existing open source software
out there that does stuff related to
math or solving math but doesn't
necessarily show a step-by-step solution
or doesn't like focus on the teaching
aspect of it and so as far as I know
mass deaths is like the first open
source teaching focused math silver
which is exciting so at this point you
might be wondering how did we build it
and that is what we're going to talk
about next so the input is ASCII math
just like letters and numbers and
symbols that you can type out on a
keyboard that's parsed into a parse tree
and then you iterate over that tree a
bunch of times applying a bunch of
different possible simplifications and
then at some point you decide that
there's like no more simplifications
that can be done and then we say that
we've reached the simplest most
simplified form which again like all
these things are like kind of arbitrary
but we'll get into that so the first
part parsing input this is kind of what
I meant by ASCII math so you can see
here like the two for x squared it's not
like a little tiny two in the corner
like you got literally it's like X
Charat to
so these are like things you could type
out on your keyboard and when you look
at this you might think like oh I can
see that that one plus two is in
parentheses in your mind kind of like
groups that into a chunk or you see the
minus three and you know that that's an
argument to the absolute value function
or you could use your knowledge of order
of operations and know that the
multiplication part happens before the
subtraction part how could we put this
into some data structure that a computer
can also apply this knowledge a first
tree okay so math Jess is this really
awesome open source math library and
they have a really great par and it
makes this tree and it was really
helpful and mattress is great and so the
way this works you can see here like the
one plus two is in its like own subtree
the minus three is a argument to the
absolute value function so like all the
kinds of things that you post in your
mind was also parsed into this tree and
that becomes really helpful for the
algorithm at this point I kind of wanted
to go back to that thing I said earlier
where there is existing open source math
tools that are not necessarily suited
for like a step-by-step solution or for
something focused on teaching and here's
like a really good example so computer
algebra system is a really cool piece of
technology it like takes in math like a
string of math and it can simplify or
solve things for you and a bunch of
other stuff and me going into this
project was like oh I'll just take this
and then I'll like look in the code in
like find each step-by-step part and
like take that out because of course a
computer is doing something like a human
does no not at all I was looking at some
PI which is like a Python computer
algebra system and when I parsed X minus
y plus 2/3 it like immediately turn it
into this other tree which was X plus
minus 1 times y which is like kind of
like minus y but not plus 2 times 3 2
minus 1 so there's never learned
division there's only multiplication by
the inverse and I was like well this is
great now if I want to do a step by step
solution I have like no idea what the
user inputted originally
and like how do there's like no way and
I was confused at first why simply might
do that but honestly like their goal is
to get to the solution and if they don't
have as many operations now they only
have addition multiplication and
exponentiation there's no more division
or subtraction so there's less stuff for
them to deal with so it's better for
their goal and the goal of the computer
algebra system is the answer our goal is
a step-by-step solution so even as early
and like the algorithm design as just
like what data structure are we going to
use we are like already going down
different paths another thing that we
came across while designing our tree was
realizing that arithmetic operations are
binary by that I mean I was like
scanning two plus three plus four like
putting that through the parser I was
expecting like one plus node with three
children two three and four but instead
I got like two plus three plus four or
two plus three plus four that's like why
is this tree binary why that doesn't
make sense to my like the way that I
think about math and turns out that's
like actually the way the plus operator
is defined like it's an addition between
the left side of the plus operator and
the right side of the fuss operator and
that's like how it works but because
plus and also multiplication they're
both commutative and associative so like
we think of it in our minds as if it's
just like an n Airy operation and it can
have any number of arguments and I was
like okay well like maybe this binary
tree will be fine like we'll see what
happens and then I got to something like
this this kind of thing comes up a lot
like collecting and combining like terms
you find the two x's and group them
together and the two twos and add them
together and it was really hard with a
tree that is all like spread out like
that when you have a binary tree they
after like kind of iterate over it and
figure out like what arguments are
candidates for collecting and it was not
fun and I was like well the way that we
do it as humans is we just look at all
the things that are being added together
for things that are similar and so we
flattened the tree and it was way easier
or actually converting over to a new
parser soon
and that my friend Kevin at Khan Academy
is working on and it will parse the tree
automatically and flatten it
automatically as it as it's parsing
which I'm excited about so we have a
tree that's great now we need to do the
steps we need a simplify things step by
step
ooh baby you gotta get to you girl I
don't know until I started my internship
and then my like intern mentor was
singing it a lot and then I was like
stuck in my head for four months and I
just want to share that wait so now
we're simplifying things step by step
the reason that simplification is such
like a big thing this is most of what
massdep's does there's lots of other
things you can do in math but I think at
the end usually you're simplifying your
answer or a lot of like questions that
students have in like early school or
like mid middle school is around
simplifying stuff so that's what we
focus on and an example of a simplifying
rule would be something like something
to the zero simplifying to one or taking
two numbers and adding them together or
the one in the bottom right is like
combining the 2x and the X to become 3x
and the way that we match a rule like
this is with at research so for example
the rule something to the zero becoming
one you can go through the tree try to
find something that's an exponent node
and then try to see what their exponent
is zero and if both of those things are
true then you can replace that whole
thing with a one and that's how like all
of the rules work it looks through the
tree tries to find a matching rule and
then it will like replace that with
whatever the simplified version is as a
note so those of you that are like what
if it's zero to the zero that's
undefined I know and we don't do things
all right now it's all my mine and like
adding capability for like catching
errors and I like how that would work
and what it would return and stuff is
something we're exploring right now
so you're welcome to contribute to that
so that's pretty much how it works we
have some ascii input we purse it we do
a bunch of tree searches to try to match
rules and we simplify so we can have a
step-by-step solution now but I don't
think that that's like the most
interesting part of this I think the
part that gets really neat is like not
just a step by step solution but a good
one
one that has steps that are like
intuitive and like teach well and so
there's like so many things that we
could do to do that and lots that we
haven't done yet but I want to share
some of the things that we've done so
far so one thing is the way that we
structure the tree search so we were
just talking about tree searches here
yeah so searching through the tree
matching a rule there are two different
ways that it can do that search one is a
post order search which tests the parent
for the rule post it's children so look
at the children first if the rule didn't
match then you check the parent app
reader search will check the parent
first and that can change how the
solution looks so for the rule something
to the 0 is 1 if we were using a post
order search and looking at the children
first and someone and put it something
like X to the 0 to the 0 which I know
doesn't really make that much like and
all that many people would ask that but
it's possible what that would simplify
to you is it would look deeper in the
tree first and it would match them more
like inside X to the 0 see what have X
to the 0 to the 0 becoming 1 to the 0
and then the next time it would become 1
but if we had a pre-order search it
could just become one right away which I
think makes more sense it like if you
have a really big expression all to the
power of 0 and you can just make that
one and algorithms often we like to take
shortcuts if we can and not do extra
work and teaching sometimes that like
not doing extra work thing is not great
for teaching but I think in this case it
does make sense so that search is in
math steps as preorder search but some
searches are better as post order
searches for example like adding numbers
together is only going to match at the
bottom of the tree so it may as well
look at the bottom of the tree first
and that is more efficient so some posts
order some pre-order
for like algorithmic efficiency
sometimes but mostly just for like
optimizing learning like in this case
another question that get a lot is like
how do you choose which simplification
to happen first this is like a screen
video of the our code and this is like
all the different rules that you can
possibly match there's like a whole
bunch of them and it's only a very small
subset of existing math and how do we
pick which one happens first like often
it's arbitrary but there are reasons why
sometimes we do certain rules first so
this is how it's structured in the code
we have this list of tree searches each
like group is a certain category of
search so the first one is basic
searches so the one that we just saw
something to the zero is one may as well
do that first because if that's like the
whole question then we're done or
something like something to this time
zero is zero or something times one is
itself like I said to just kind of clean
that up at the beginning and that's why
that one those searches happen first if
none of those rules can be matched
anywhere in the tree then we go on to
this next one that I just like to put
high up because I really don't like the
way that that looks like two over x over
six this look very confusing to look at
but it is legal to parse and so someone
could put that in there and then you can
just multiply by the inverse and that
kind of like standardizes the way that
things look so that people aren't seeing
weird things that confuse them but also
the algorithm can assume that like a
fraction I'd like to have a numerator
denominator that's like also a fraction
that's confusing another thing that we
do to try to teach well is think about
like good teaching isn't necessarily
there like most simple or basic or like
the fewest steps sometimes need to show
a bit more detail and so here we have
like x times x squared becoming x cubed
and even in writing the code for this i
was like okay how where does the 3 come
from on you to like figure out what the
new exponent is and i think it would be
the same for a human that is like trying
to learn this for the first time or
still working on it
and the answer is you add the exponents
together but then you might be like
where did that one come from there's no
one well X is the same as X to the one
and then you can add the 1 and the 2
together and then you get 3 and that was
something that I had to do and
programming it and it's also something
that like a human might need to know and
so it's important to like expose those
steps and show those details when it's
something new to someone so that they
can understand it pretty much just like
having pedagogical goals where pedagogy
is just like a word for teaching theory
like caring about teaching makes things
more complex so it could have more code
there could be more output but that like
creates a better learning experience so
we'll do that however complexity can
make things more complex and we had this
technical complexity issue here where we
were having these steps for adding
fractions it's like a thing that a lot
of students have trouble with because
there's a lot there's a lot to it the
first step is to work towards having a
common denominator and you might notice
that like in that process it gets a
little bit like less simplified even
though we're going towards something
that's more simplified and so at this
point in math steps we were just doing
one step and then without any context
figuring out what the next step was so
just keeping going through coming up
with a new rule that matches but that
gets like a little weird here because 2
times 5 over 3 times 5 without any like
context you cancel the 5 then you go
through everything again and you're like
oh we need to add fractions so let's
multiply by 5 on the top on the bottom
and then those stairs like oh those
fives need to be cancelled out I was
like no what are you going to do and
then I tried moving the order of the
rules around so that like the right
thing would happen first before like the
other thing but like then other things
broke I was like how do humans know what
did you like they just know that they're
in the middle of adding fractions so now
we just group all of these steps
together we know that we're adding
fractions and then we do all of the
steps and sequence and then return them
all together a sub steps of
the step adding fractions and this is
awesome for like so many reasons one of
them is to avoid this infinite loop
situation another one is like we don't
have to do all the work going through
all those possible steps to figure out
what's happening next like you know
what's gonna happen next we're adding
fractions like that's the next thing
that happens and it also is really nice
for this is the demo a screenshot of it
but you can collapse those sub steps so
let's say you like already know how
adding fractions work and you don't want
to see the details you don't have to see
the details you can collapse them or
maybe you want to know how it works and
you can expand it it just gives more
context for what's going on which is
really great when there's a lot of steps
and you don't understand that math you
can like pick and choose when to see
certain details and this is really
helpful for this case too like I said
the bottom line was best when you don't
know how this math works but if you know
that X is the same as X to the one
having that show as a step every time
can be really annoying so having the
option to show that as detail is really
awesome so now we've talked about a
bunch of ways that math steps teach as
well but there are also a lot of ways
that it could teach better or are just
limitations of things it could never do
and I want to make sure that like in my
talk I make sure that about the
limitations of technology cuz like
technologies I'm going to like make the
world like perfect and just like a
step-by-step solvers and going to like
solve all of math education and so I
want to make sure that I talk about that
so this is kind of like come up a couple
times
like how many stuffs do you show like
sometimes if you show a lot of steps
people like really like that and they
like to see all the details sometimes if
you show like 30 steps the students will
be like no math is hard that's too much
I don't like it put it away and they'll
be scared off maybe they know a bunch of
details of something and you don't need
to show that to them like they already
know how that works and it's boring or
annoying or maybe there's something that
you don't show them that like is very
key for them understanding how it works
so how many steps to show just like
depends on the problem which we do have
and this
student which we know nothing about
because it's just an algorithm different
people solve math differently this also
so this could be like the final solution
eight over five and we can show eight
over five as an improper fraction
but in grade 3 I was told to leave it as
an extraction and university I was told
to leave it as a decimal so people might
be looking for a specific answer and
maybe we're not giving them that answer
because we have no idea what they want
unless we ask and messed up doesn't ask
right now we also don't ask how they
want to solve the question so we might
so there's like the answer but there's
also all the steps along the way so when
I see this this is like multiplying two
binomials the way that I learned to do
it was you take the first term you
multiply it by all the terms on the
right then you take the second one you
multiply it by all the terms on the
right if there was a third term I would
also multiply it by all the terms on the
right like I know how to like expand
this to any kind of multiplying things
by each other but a lot of people learn
this as foil anyone learn this as foil
in school yeah so there's the first the
outer inner and last and that's how you
know what the answer is until you add a
third term in either the vertices and
then students are like I have no idea
what to do because they don't know how
the math works it's a mnemonic it
teaches it memorized it's a way to
memorize how this math works but it's
not like the why and so they can't
really like expand that and so I try to
avoid mnemonics when in math steps
because I feel like it's not a good
teaching tool but also some people might
get confused because different people
solve math differently and maybe they're
doing a homework and at the top is like
use foil to answer these questions and
then they're like am I supposed to use
foil here they don't mention foil at all
what's going on and like close it so
there's this like weird balance between
relevant and useful to the education
system like stuff that they're learning
in school and stuff that is like
relevant to like the education system as
it is right now which has its flaws and
then there's like teaching to help
learning which is like some
best way of teaching we're like we're
really like helping people understand
how it works there's all this research
that's been done about like totally
different ways to teach math that like
different fundamentals of learning and
that would be like really cool but like
would anyone use it would it be helpful
to anyone there's like some balance
there and so that's like really hard but
like is there even a fast way of solving
something teaching something like I
don't think its objective and so a lot
of stuff that we do in math steps is
like kind of arbitrary or it's just at
least what we think is the best and
sometimes it's just this one seems fine
and finally I want to make sure and when
we're talking about limitations that a
step-by-step solution isn't like a full
teaching tool right it's just like a
cool technical problem it's not a lesson
plan or like a full in-depth explanation
of why and it's not gonna like fix all
of math education it's just a tool that
can be used like within the system and
people use it to solve their homework
which means it can be used to cheat I
don't know if you ever use like Wolfram
Alpha or these things to like you know
oh I don't know how to do that integral
and I like me to get some stuff by step
solution that will teach me how to do it
you know it we all have done it I think
and it is the thing that this kind of
technology is used for and so I just
like keep that in mind but there are
things that we can do that can make this
kind of technology better for learning
and there are things that this kind of
technology could like maybe things that
can be built on top of it that can also
help so lots of cool like opportunities
for stuff in the future and I talked
about that a little bit now so whenever
we do at research we know that we're
adding fractions at this point wouldn't
it be cool if since we know you're
adding fractions or like hey check out
this video on Khan Academy
how to add fractions or even like a sub
step like hey you want to learn more
about least common multiple here's a
video about it because we already know
this information
we're like matching these rules already
or
what if I let hey you're adding
fractions this person over here is also
adding fractions and want to talk about
adding fractions together it's like
silly in this example but also teaching
your peers and like talking about the
problems that you're having with each
other is one of the best ways to learn
and so I think it would be really cool
if people could talk if we knew that of
a group of people all working on the
same kind of math to give them a place
to talk about that with each other
because learning with other people is
often more effective than just being by
yourself copying down the answer rate
ways to know how much detail the show
this looks like come up a lot I think
there's a couple of different ways that
we could do this you could notice like
when do they expand sub steps when are
they really wanted to see more detail
maybe we can just keep that expanded by
default or maybe you can look at the
whole question and be like is this just
a very small part of this very big
problem then they probably don't need
the details at all but if it's they're
just asking that particular thing then
you can show them the details or like
you could just ask them hey is this kind
of thing a thing that you know and
they're like yes and then you can stop
giving them how to do that part and then
eventually you can like it know the
learner and you can only show them
exactly the steps that are most useful
to them which is pretty much what human
tutors do and that's some a lot of I
think what is missing and something like
math steps is getting to know the
learner and be able to personalize
things more another thing that I think
would be really cool from our steps to
do is get more context and like just a
string of math cuz like an equation you
can solve it you can also graph it you
can also factor it which one did I ask
we don't know if we just solve the
equation and hope that's what they were
asking for or even like what variable
are they solving for mm-hm
and often when people are like doing
this kind of homework they have written
at the top some words that explain what
the question is so it would be great to
have that context as well because that's
how humans usually solve math not just a
string there's like instructions that go
along with it so there's more than just
the string more than just this tree like
how can we expand this data structure to
show more information another example of
more information you might warrant
is let's say we have an equation like
this and we're dividing by X minus three
on the top and the bottom at this point
you just have X plus five equals zero
but some of you might be like don't
forget X can't equal three cuz if it did
you'd be dividing by zero
I forgot this a lot in high school this
is like one of those like edge case
things but if this was the question
there would be no solution and if you
didn't remember that X can't be three
you would be lying which I think my
stuff says right now so you want to be
careful to like keep this extra
information of what the range of certain
variables can be and there's like lots
of stuff that comes up like this things
that aren't just in the expression that
you want to you store cuz that's how
humans solve math this one's my favorite
but I feel like people would never use
it or you make them guess this is a
little human tutor can do they set you
down and you have no choice they're like
what do you think comes next and you're
like I have no idea no like just guess
you're like okay and that's how you
learn but I think that if this was like
in some kind of app you might feel like
no screw this I'm gonna go for alpha so
you know some balance but definitely
this is a great way to learn and finally
machine learning it could be cool to
like train some kind of like model take
like a bunch of examples of good step by
step solutions whatever good means I
don't know and then training on that and
then you could like provide a
step-by-step solution for any problem I
have no idea if this is possible or how
would be done or if we have like enough
technology for it to provide like really
good step-by-step solutions but if any
if you are like interested in machine
learning and have ideas about it I would
love to chat more about it because
that's like kind of neat to think about
so now we talked about all the cool
things that you can do with math steps
you might be wondering this is so cool I
wish I could contribute to it and it's
open source so you can it's written in
JavaScript all es6 it's just like pure
like it's just an algorithm and you can
find it at that URL we have a bunch of
small tasks that should be accessible to
someone that even knows like barely
anything about the project and you
already know a lot about how it works
now so you're like past that point
anyways
we have a bunch of really great tests
they're cool because it can just be like
a string that is parsed and then it does
a bunch of steps and then it prints it
at the end so all the tests are just
like this string becomes that string and
this pretty much is like a step by step
solution that you can look at and figure
out how the step by step solutions work
so you can see how math steps does all
of the things it does but just looking
at the tests all right we have a
contributing document there's lots of
improvements if you like already talked
about some things that mass steps could
do that you could work on bug fixes and
even if you just want to like talk about
algorithm design and writing algorithms
that are optimized for teaching I'd be
damned to chat about that any time here
are some numbers to show how popular we
are but more important than that look
where all of our contributors are from
like a cool community from around the
world if you're from any of the
countries that don't have a pin on them
you should contribute so you can have a
pin and if your country is now on this
map because I cropped it um I'm sorry
especially for from Australia
um so we have a demo but I just made
like this past week so now you can like
play with it and see how it works you
can also download the socratic app and
see how that works
I also it's like on NPM so you can link
install it and play with it or you can
just like fork it and edit the code and
do some cool stuff and then make a pull
request to it can treat your cool code
back and that's it thanks so much for
listening if any of you want to come and
talk about any this with me I would love
to you chat I hope to see you around
thank you
[Applause]